bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débats de
chroniqu et de reportag 90 minutes pour
donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société et voici le
sommaire de ce 28 novembre plus de 6
Français sur 10 souhaite le départ
d'Élisabeth borne de Matignon et 71 %
d'entre eux pensent qu'elle ne ferait
pas non plus une bonne tête de liste aux
élections européennes notre baromètre
politique de novembre n'est pas tendre
pour la première ministre alors que des
rumeurs de remanimement repartent DEP
belle qui est le mieux placé pour la
remplacer Emmanuel Macron peut-il
changer d'équipe dès le mois de janvier
quel impact le conflit Israël Hamas mais
aussi les faits divers récents ont sur
l'opinion on en débat dans une minute et
puis pour notre second thème je vous
propose l'histoire d'une réforme
difficile à mettre en œuvre la
légalisation de l'ethanasie on a assisté
jusqu'à la fin de ville maman donc on
était tous autour d'elle quand le
médecin a a pratiqué enfin en tout cas a
fait la piqûure
létal et il c'était tellement paisible
parce que dans un premier temps elle
s'endort et puis et puis le cœur
s'arrête près de nef Français sur 10
souhaitent légaliser l'euthanasie
c'était une promesse de campagne du
candidat Macron et pour pourtant le
Président de la République hésite
pourquoi un tel flottement alors que le
projet de loi existe il est écrit que
changerait précisément cette réforme
comment cette pratique est-elle encadrée
notamment en Belgique réponse dans tris
qu4 d'heure mais d'abord les
enseignements du baromètre odoxa mascaré
pour Public Sénat et les journaux de la
presse quotidienne régionale on commence
avec les personnalités politique préféré
des Français Jonathan Dupriez c'est l'un
des principaux enseignements de notre
baromètre xa pour public sénna publié
aujourd'hui dans un contexte
international tendu notamment avec le
conflit Israël Hamas des responsable
politique de premier plan gagne en
popularité porté par l'effet drapeau a
commencé par Édouard Philippe l'ancien
Premier ministre donné comme
présidentiable possible pour 2027
Caracol en tête du classement avec 44 %
d'opinion favorable il est quand même
maire évidemment d'une ville moyenne
plus mais relativement importante il
arrive aussi à toujours avoir une parole
justement présidentiable si je puis dire
c'est-à-dire on ne Cliffe pas trop on
rassure et on est toujours un peu
au-dessus derrière lui deux
personnalités se détachent execo Marine
Le Pen et Gabriel Atal atteignent 38 %
de code d'adhésion ABAA dans les écoles
attentat à haras les sujets délicats de
la rentrée ont porté le jeune ministre
de l'éducation nationale au tout premier
plan de la tenstion médiatique on a un
Gabriel Atal qui n'était pas non plus
extrême connu avant d'arriver à
l'éducation nationale or il y a un effet
de nouveauté évidemment nous qui sommes
dans le je dirais dans la vie politique
qui connaiss son ça on a trèsôt
identifier que et bien gabrielal pouvait
être un pilier de la macronie l'autre
élément c'est qu'il a su extrêmement
bien jouer sur les outils de
communication parallèlement le couple
exécutif semble être en inversion de
phase d'un côté Emmanuel Macron en
surplomb avec les crises internationales
gagne 5 points de popularité en 6 mois
pour atteindre 35% d'opinion favorable
toutefoisisabeth born plus exposé
d'un desux de l'opinion 69% des sondés
jugent qu'elle est une mauvaise première
ministre on a toujours la volonté pour
le président de la République de mettre
un Premier ministre qui joue à la fois
le rôle de paratonire et en même temps
le rôle de fusible et donc évidemment
dès le moment où la situation politique
se gade le moment où vous avez des
tensions sociales dans le pays et bien
le Premier ministre prend dès lors qu'il
est mis en avant autre renseignement à
gauche Jean-Luc Mélenchon plonge dans
l'opinion avec seulement 18 % de code
d'adhésion au cœur de de polémique ces
dernières semaines notamment son refus
de considérer le Hamas comme
organisation terroriste l'ancien
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
voit son leadership à gauche c'est
moussé de mois en
mois et on détaille les résultats de
notre baromètre avec Céline brac bonsoir
directrice générale deodxa bienvenue à
vous Sophie coagard bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste éditorialiste
Politi au point Mathieu souquer bonsoir
et bienvenue consultant et spécialisé en
sciences politiques on est également en
duplexe avec Yv SAN seigneor partner
chez mascaré bonsoir Yve et laetia crupa
éditorialiste politique bonsoir latitia
bienvenue à vous on commence par
l'ancien Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe si vous le voulez bien cé line
brac comment expliquer ce cette
régularité au au sommet est-ce que c'est
la rareté de sa parole qu'il sert
également oui alors pas seulement
c'està-dire qu'il a une personnalité qui
même lorsqu'il était Premier Ministre
faisait de lui une personnalité
appréciée il était il il avait un une
code de personnalité haute pour un
premier ministre est stable dans le
temps alors la stabilité c'est pas
toujours le cas parce que sur le
baromètre politique on a vu notamment
que pendant la période des retraites et
bien comme les ministres en poste et
bien Édouard Philippe qui n'était
pourtant pas comment dire en ligne de
front sur ce pr
Lig voilà mais il il il a été considéré
par l'opinion comme un soutien de cette
réforme extrêmement impopulaire il a
perdu beaucoup de
puis depuis tout le monde remonte et
Édouard Philippe qui est en tête
maintenant depuis des mois et bien on
remonte lui aussi maintenant il faut
quand même se méfier de ce petit effet
Simon veille Bernard couchner vous voyez
qui était très très haut de de des
baromètres politiques de Paris Match
pendant très longtemps parce que
précisément ils étaient quand même hop
un pas derrière les autres un peu en
retraitah pas complètement justement de
sur la politique nationale et donc il
faut voir ce qui va se passer quand si
il le souhaite d'ailleurs s'il devient à
nouveau un représentant politique
national et qui le veut se présenter par
exemple à la prochaine présidentielle
hasard à la présidentielle Sophie coager
est-ce que vous trouvez des points
communs entre les les les trois
personnalités on va revoir le le le
baromètre les trois personnalités qui
arrivent sur le bonium et Édouard
Philippe on l'a dit et gabrielal Marine
Le Pen Exec à 38 % d'opinion favorable
ces trois là quel point commun si si on
doit en trouver bah sil faut je dirais
que leur point commun surtout dans
l'actualité de ces dernières semaines
c'est qu'ils ont parlé cach si je puis
dire c'est-à-dire que ils sont exprimer
de façon ils n'ont pas refusé l'obstacle
du clivage voilà pour le dire autrement
bon Marine Le Pen de toute façon elle
est dans son rôle c'est-à-dire bon
certes des diabolisations mais enfin
quand même il faut continuer à à tracer
en parlant en parlant fort et Gabriel
Atal évidemment c'est c'est la grande
surprise la grande vedette de cette
rentrée politique dans la majorité on
voit bien que il pe dire qu'il parle le
cach bah il ne mâche pas ses mots
c'est-à-dire ni il ne mâche ses mots si
vous enfin je veux dire les questions au
Gouvernement sont un exercice dans
lequel il il y va très fort où il refuse
jamais y compris de pointer ses
adversaires politiques du doigt je pense
notamment à la France insoumise et puis
même sur les sujets abordés un ministre
de l'Éducation qui en l'espace de 2
semaines dit qu'éventuellement on va on
va faire des groupes de niveau et qu'on
va réfléchir à redonner un peu
d'importance au
redoublement normalement c'est ce qui
s'appelle du suicide rue de Grenel parce
que le clerger le clergé pédagogique
n'est pas absolument enchanté par ce
genre de chos donc là ils doivent être
en train d'ôter de rage mais néanmoins
Gabriel Atal s'est affranchi de tout
cela ça veut dire que ça plaît à
l'opinion publique ça plat à l'opinion
public alors j'allais en venir à ça mais
alors sous votre contrôle et et quant à
Édouard Philippe je pense que sa prise
de position sur la guerre entre Israël
Israël et le Hamas notamment en disant
écoutez excusez-moi mais une guerre
c'est une guerre et ça fait des morts
c'est moche mais c'est comme ça je
résume mais c'était la T av rappé
notamment ce qui le le le le dessin de
sa ville du Havre pendant la seconde
guerre tout à fait tout à fait et bien
est une position qui tranche notamment
par rapport à celle un peu fl tuante du
président de la République donc voilà ce
que j'appelle par les caches et je pense
qu'évidemment c'est apprécié par une
opinion publique qui est majoritairement
enquête d'autorité c'est je pense que
vous montre toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion il y a il y a un autre élément
une autre leçon qu'on peut tirer Mathieu
souquier quand on revoit là ce ces cinq
premiers en tout cas il y a c'est un
match majorité présidentielle
rassemblement national oui alors ce mat
ce match là est installé depuis
longtemps moi pardon je me par un petit
petit complément je je je comprends pas
bien en fait le la petite surcôte
d'eddouard Philippe et même globalement
alors je je c'est un c'est un homme
politique qui a des d'incontestables
qualités euh il a géré la crise
sanitaire en particulier avec un certain
talent il n'empêche que en terme de sens
politique on se souvient que il est
sorti de Matignon avec une côte de
popularité très élevée alors que on a
quand même en tête qu'il a conseillé à
plusieurs reprises au président de la
République et plus que conseillé il a
réussi à convaincre le Président de la
République d'un certain nombre de
décisions qui sont assez mal passées
dans le pays la limitation de vitesse à
80 kmh c'était pas un carton plein euh
c'est l'un des
facteurscl et puis même un certain
nombre de de de décisions qui aurait pu
être prise pendant le covid précisément
confinement prolongé et cetera je dirais
que de ce point de vue là il est assez
le le fils spirituel de son père
politique à savoir alin Jupé c'est a une
capacité alors quelqu'un
d'incontestablement compétent avec une
forme d'or de charisme et de culture
mais avec quand même une capacité de
temps à ne pas totalement saisir donc
vous dites quoi attention popularité
potentiellement friable c'est ça je en
tout cas à ce stade elle ne s'effrite
pas mais je à titre personnel elle me
questionne et puis sur sur les deux
qu'on évoquait pardon Gabriel Atal il
est précisément au pouvoir enfin Gabriel
Atal et Marine Le Pen ne sont pas dans
la même situation une est dans
l'opposition là où l'autre est au
pouvoir et l'une monte quand elle agit
peu quand elle se tait quand elle se
cache moins elle en fait mieux elle se
porte Gabriel Atal au contraire
évidemment al parce qu'il est au
gouvernement et parce que
c'estt le mois dernier pardonnez-moi sit
pas totalement cachée Marie Le Pen elle
a même même saturé saturé manifest sans
se faireer c'est son talent désorisoite
peut manifester en T de cortèg non non
c'est vrai mais il y a une stratégie qui
quand même dans l'opposition consiste à
à faire un minimum de vague là où
gabrielition d'extrême droite parce qu'à
l'extrême gauche on fait beaucoup de
vagu oui oui oui s'agissant de Marine Le
Pen j'imagine qu'on discutera ensuite du
match Mélanchon Le Pen on parlera de
Jean-Luc mélencho un peu plus tard je
voudrais qu'on continue là on a montré
les C premiers mais si on descend de de
de deux de deux CR de deux étages c'est
une BR qu'on trouve Mario maréchal ouais
Mario maréchal 7e position 27 % de côte
de côte d'adhésion en fait est-ce que ça
se traduit for forcément pardon en en
intention de vote pour les européennes
puis qu' les tête de liste aux
Européennes pour le mouvement reconquête
d'éc Zemmour alors pour l'instant en
intention de vote européenne finalement
euh le la liste reconquête est autour
des 7 % ce qui devrait la situer à un
niveau proche de ce qu'elle avait pu
faire précédemment et qui la situe euh
proche aussi de LR donc ce serait un
score euh plutôt honorable mais euh ce
que j'allais dire sur sur Mario maréchal
Le Pen c'est qu'elle fait vraiment
partie des personnalités qui compent à
droite mais que son étoile a quand même
P euh en 1 an 1 an et demi parce que
souvenez-vous euh en terme de popularité
quand on regardait les sondages euh elle
était très très proche de sa tante de
Marion de de Marine Le Pen et euh donc
un peu de temps avant la présidentielle
elle a même déjà dépassé Marine Le Pen
et il y a tous les commentaires
politiques à un moment c'était de dire
bon allez bientôt le temps de Marine Le
Pen va être terminé et c'est Marion
maréchal qui la remplacera ce qui fait
que son choix stratégique d'aller chez
reconquête alors voilà c'est un choix
qui est aussi un choix d'adhésion
certainement à ce parti-là mais
stratégiquement on peut pas dire que ce
soit un Fran succès parce que certes
elle est beaucoup plus populaire qu'erc
Zemour elle est beaucoup moins rejetée
qu'Eric Zemour maintenant elle est quand
même seconde division et on parle de
Marine Le Pen donc donc elle est quand
même Marine Le Pen est à est donc la 3e
avec 38 % elle elle est à 27 % en 7e
position donc 11 points derrière et
entre deux et bien il y a Jordan
bardellaa qui fait un carton qui plaît
beaucoup aux sympathisants l'extrême
droite mais pas mal aussi aux
sympathisants de droite donc tout ce
qu'on disait de Marion maréchal Le Pen
ce rapprochement possible entre
l'extrême droite et la droite
aujourd'hui c'est plus attribué
spontanément à Jordane Bela qu'à
Marchal alors je vis qu'on parle
maintenant de d'Emmanuel Macron avec un
président de la République qui profite
plutôt du contexte
international le chef de l'État remercié
hier par certaines familles d'otage
français libéré par le Hamas
écoutez j'aimerais remercier le
président Biden pour le soutien
extraordinaire qu'il a apporté à la
concrétisation de ce
moment ainsi que le président français
Emmanuel Macron et l'ambassade de France
ici en Israël pour leur soutien
extraordinaire
Emmanuel Macron qui voit sa sa code de
popularité est-il un bon Président de la
République c'est la question posée par
notre baromètre réponse non 65 % oui en
légère progression plus un point à 35 %
je me tourne vers IFV sens une première
fois dans notre débat peut-être pour un
point général sur ce conflit Israël
Hamas est-ce qu'il pèse toujours autant
dans les conversations sur les réseaux
sociaux ou est-ce que c'est plutôt un
peu en train de se tarir ou de se tasser
alors en effet on c'estant le conflit en
lui-même ou en tout cas les débats
français issus du conflit ont ont
quelques peu changer de nature on avait
vu sur le dernier baromètre que la la
pénétration était très puiss
l'exportation du débat du conflit était
très puissant dans le pays elle a
tendance à ralentir à affaiblir par
contre très clairement le débat direct
sur le conflit israellli-palestinien
s'est transféré sur la question euh de
l'antisémitisme qui laisse des traces
politiques profondes on évoquait tout à
l'heure la la question de de Marine Le
Pen euh d'abord le premier point c'est
que les plus gros pics sur sur les
réseaux sociaux ça a été les polémiques
autour de Guillaume meuce par exemple ou
alors de la marche sur l'antisémitisme
contre
l'antisémitisme mais sur ce deuxème
point le vrai sujet qui a mobilisé le le
grand public ce sont les probl les les
polémiques autour des des partis LFI et
RN avec une Marine Le Pen qui a très
clairement engrangé des chiffres qui a
améliorer
euh l'IM sa propre image qui a
probablement transformé la
perception pivot de l'anti de du Front
national à l'époque qui était considéré
comme le parti antisémite avec une
Marine Le Pen
aujourd'hui qui euh passe quasiment dans
le C vert face à elle Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ça a été viendra plus tard de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je vous interrom tout de suite
faut pas tout dire dans la dans la
première intervention il s si vous savez
on en reparlera plus tard de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Guillaume Meuris vous avez
fait référence humoriste de France
interre évidemment qui s'était retrouvé
au cœur d'une polémique pour avoir dans
une chronique traitée Benyamin netanahou
de nazi sans prépus pour ceux qui ne
l'auraient pas vu je voudrais qu'on
qu'on justement qu'on discute de de
cette manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme Marine Le Pen y était et
pas Emmanuel Macron Sophie Coignard
est-ce qu'il y a une erreur stratégique
de l'un et une victoire de l'autre bah
sur la sur la victoire enfin oui sur la
réussite de cette séquence par Marine Le
Pen je crois que il y a enfin c'est
difficile de de de le nier ou de le
contester c'est sûr que elle a
elle a engrangé
euh vraisemblablement sur ce sur sur
cette euh sur cette journée et elle a
euh comment dirais-je elle a engrangé et
en plus elle a enfin elle
a marqué une une comment vous dire un
point de N retour c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui euh et bien effectivement le
RN dans une manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme ça s'est déjà vu et donc
comment vous dire c'est c'est une espèce
de de case qui est coché quoi qu'il en
soit puisque ça s'est pas si mal passé
pour elle elle s'est pas elle s'est pas
pris des œufs pourris euh euh sur sur
elle pendant tout le pendant pendant
tout le défilé Emmanuel Macron c'est
très difficile de trancher à titre
personnel je pense qu'il a commis une
erreur je pense qu'il a commis une
erreur et que
cette cette erreur ben peut avoir des
conséquences assez durables non
seulement à cause de son absence mais à
cause des motifs qu'ila donné de cette
absence souvenez-vous quand il a été
interpellé par l'arrière petite fille je
crois crois d'Alfred drefus et il a dit
un c'est pas dans mes habitudes d'aller
manifester ce qui me paraît un peu ença
de la strature de la stature
présidentielle pour rester très aimable
et la deuxième chose qu'il a dit c'est
sinon je pourrais aller manifester
toutes les semaines et très sincèrement
je trouve que ça lui a été très peu
reproché par rapport à ce que ça aurait
pu être quand je l'ai entendu dire ça
j'ai vraiment eu le sentiment qu'il
allait le entre guillemets le pays trs
ch et finalement dans le dans leestom
effectivement des critiques des uns et
des autres et ce et des polémiques s
passé inaperçu je pense que à la fois la
décision et surtout la justification
n'était pas à la hauteur de de la
situation d'ailleurs on le voit dans
notre baromètre puisqu'il progresse même
faiblement il progresse à 35 % d'opinion
favorable Mathieu souquier est-ce que
finalement il on a vu effectivement un
président de la République
voilà je fais ce ce terme-là sur un sur
une question aussi majeure que le la la
la Renaissance si j'ose dire du conflit
au au proch Orient euh et il le paye pas
politiquement comment vous l'analysez
ouais écoutez c'est pareil il y a pas la
vie est parfois faite de paradoxe et la
vie politique n'est pas faite que de
rationalité c'est vrai que sur
l'international focalisation sur
l'international en général évidemment ça
redor la stature présidentielle ça fait
du bien pour autant comme vous le
rappeliez la séquence a été complexe
pour lui d'abord il y a eu une visite
là-bas qui est venue de façon très
tardive c'estàd que un certain nombre de
chefs d'État ou de chefs de gouvernement
ont précédé ont même largement précédé
Emmanuel Macron au Proche Orient SH est
passé avant mellonie est passé avant
enfin donc on avait l'impression que la
France avait un tout petit peu tardé il
avait dit j'irai quand ce sera utile
ouais c'est ça et alors justement il est
allé quand il a jugé que c'était utile
mais en faisant un certain nombre de
propositions qu'à peu près toutes les
chancelleries ont derrière retoquer
alors de façon très diplomatique mais
quand même de façon extrêmement claire
donc on n' pas compris qu'il avait à ce
moment-là récupérer le le leadership au
plan international et effectivement la
marche sur le la marche contre
l'antisémitisme il a semblé à front
alors à front renversé après plusieurs
jours on avait compris qu'il
tergiversait en plus c'estàd que bien
souvent on est au courant du fait que le
chef de l'État se tâte qu'il hésite
c'est peut-être oui peut-être non et à
la fin c'est non et pour le coup
précisément comme la pression était un
tout petit peu montée pendant quelques
jours on imaginait qu'il allait se
présenter à la marche en question et et
il n'y était pas peut-être juste un
dernier mot la la la précédente marche
contre l'antisémitisme ans auparavant à
l'occasion de la profanation du
cimetière juif de carpra alors non
seulement s'était transformé en marche
contre l'extrême droite c'est que le
pays avait manifesté contre
l'antisémitisme mais contre à l'époque
le rassemblement national et précisément
le chef de l'État de l'époque François
miteran était en tête de cortège et donc
30 ans après on est à front rversé ça
fait froid dans le dos c'estd que
l'extrême droite peut être là sans se
faire caillasser sans se faire
housouspiller sans se faire ch c'est
aussi mais c'est pas le sensre de de
notre débat parce que les ressorts de
l'antisémitisme ont aussi changé dans
notre pays pas en totalité mais en
partie oui oui absolument et puis on a
éc Zemour quiil y a pas si longtemps que
ça en fait a incarné la figure du Juif
revendiqué réhabilitant Pétin donc tout
ça fait aussi des dégâts considérablesou
c'est une BR vous vouliz intervenir oui
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est vrai
que vous suivez la politique de manière
extrêmement fine et épisode par épisode
il faut bien voir que c'est pas le cas
de de la plupart des Français et
c'est-à-dire qu'au moment où arrivent
des événements internationaux
généralement dans les grandes lignes les
Français les suivent et il connaissent
plutôt quand même bien les grandes
lignes et en l'occurrence ils sont tout
à fait sur les mêmes grandes lignes
qu'Emmanuel Macron c'est-à-dire quand on
les testé à la fois absolument horrifié
parce que par les par les actes du Hamas
et en même temps tout à fait solidaire
des Palestiniens de Gaza et donc
finalement quand on leur pose la
question sur les positions d'Emmanuel
Macron les Français considèrent que ils
sont tout à fait d'accord avec les
positions de d'Emmanuel Macron on avait
dit donc Emmanuel Macron a soutenu la
manifestation même s'il n'y a pas
participé et les Français disaient à la
fois on est content qu'il a soutenu
cette manifestation et on lui en
voudrait pas qu'il n'y participe pas
donc il faut voir quand même que ces
actualités là ça fait plutôt du bien à
une stature présidentielle surtout quand
on soutient les grandes lignes et
qu'après tout le détail les explications
et cetera ça passe quand même au-dessus
de la tête de la plupart des gens ouais
l'actualité politique de ce mardi elle
est encore marquée par les conséquences
du meurtre du jeune Thomas lors de cette
fête de village à crépool ça a donné
lieu à une passe d'armes à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui éc Dupont moriti
accusant l'extrême droite d'instru
mentaliser ce drame regardez je pense
aussi moi aux Français à nos
compatriotes aux Français de préférence
qui vivent dans nos quartiers dans les
cités et qui ne mérit pas de lire sur
les murs morts aux Arabes nos frères
juifs ont peur nos Frères musulmans ont
peur aussi vos propos sont
et ils amèent dans la rue les militants
de l'ultraroite qui sont bien plus
proches de vous que de moi pour être
crédiible faites le ménage chassez de
vos rang les gudards les Identitaires
les nazion les racistes les
antisémites qui sont en réalité planqués
dans vos officines économiques et qui
viennent sévèrement d'être condamné par
la cour d'appel de
Paris vu les élus du rassemblement
national quittter les l'émicyclle latiti
interven et on voit aussi ellisabeth
borne derrière sourire donc elle la
quièe elle sait que Éric dupometti peut
faire cette s là certainement ils en on
discuté avant elle connaît ses positions
et elle a quièce donc il fait pas cette
sortie tout seul ça il faut bien l'avoir
en tête et c'est vrai qu'il est aussi
dans la la logique deti depuis toujours
était enfin se veut en première ligne
dans le combat contre le rassemblement
national est-ce que pour autant Sophie
Coignard là sur ce point précis c'est la
bonne stratégie c'est un grand débat
c'est trop c'est trop tôt pour le dire
c'est trop tôt pour le dire que je voilà
que que que l'humilité m'empêche et la
lucidité m'empêche de mais le fait le
fait de pointer ce qu'il reste ce qu'il
reste d'antisémitisme au sein du
rassemblement national parce que c'est
ça sa stratégie nous amener nous
observateur à se poser un débat compris
enfin c'est un débat éternel
souvenez-vous Fabius 1984 si je ne
m'abuse qui dit il est alors Premier
ministre que le Front National et Front
national de l'époque c'était quand même
euh enfin je veux dire sur
l'antisémitisme o il y avait pas
vraiment de doute quoi euh posait de
bonnes questions et il apportait de
mauvaises réponseson ça c'est ce que
disait Laurent Fabius c'était Fabius 84
ministre Premier ministre socialiste
donc vieille histoire donc là c'est
l'idée que il faut en gros
que il ne faut pas il ne faut pas
insulter la ir et surtout les éventuels
électeurs du Front national c'était
quand même ça l'idée mais qu'il faut
essayer de leur parler et cetera et puis
vous avez la stratégie qui consiste à
dire il faut dénoncer ce qu'est la
réalité de cette extrême droite
désormais certes encravaté fardé de de
de républicanisme et de laïcité et c'est
ce qu'a fait souvenez-vous il y a
quelques temps ellisabeth borne c'est
pour
ça complètement d'accord c'est un débat
qui c'est un débat Terri enfin qui qui
qui est clivant au sein même de
l'exécutif je suis totalement d'accord
quand Elisabeth borne a dit en fait ce
parti c'est l'héritier de Pétin et
qu'elle s'est fait recadrer par le
président de la ré donc on voit bien que
ce débat n'est pas tranché et que euh
les tenant de de de la version j'allais
dire inclusive euh disent en gros c'est
ce qu'a dit euh euh Emmanuel Macron à
ellisabeth Borne écoutez ça fait 30 ans
qu'on qu'on diabolise le Front National
et cetera et on voit le résultat il n'
cessé de monter euh la question c'est si
on si on décide de ne pas faire cela
mais au contraire de de le prendre au
sérieux est-ce qu'il ne va pas monter
aussi rien de l' démonrer démonter
encore plus et finir par briser ce plond
vert qui ferme les portes de l'É pour
pour l'instant évidemment if San si je
reviens vers vous parce que évidemment
le le baromètre
d'xa n'a pas pu intégrer on va dire le
le le le fait d'hiver qui est devenu
d'ailleurs un fait politique de de
crépole mais est-ce que là si vous avez
regardé ces dernières heures ces
derniers jours à quel point ça prend la
place justement et sous quelle forme
surtout euh sur les médias sociaux tout
à fait tu vais m' tenir au au fait mais
on a un ratio de ce qu'on appelle les
engagements qui est très important sur
les les les les 30 derniers jours on va
dire c'est euh ça représente 1,7 million
de mentions c'est vraiment très
important sur les réseaux sociaux mais
sur les faits on va quand même noter
quelque chose de particulier c'est que
euh d'abord le phénomène d'extrême
droite l'agitation extrême droite sur
les réseaux sociaux elle est réelle euh
c'est-à-dire qu' au sein des résultats
les plus importants qu'on a on retrouve
principalement les noms des chantres de
l'extrême droite Marion maréchal Damien
Rieux Julien oudoule et cetera beaucoup
d'influenceurs très connus des réseaux
bassin français de sououche livre noir
et cetera le deuxième point c'est la
présence très forte qui est un peu
troublante de comptte étrangers
principalement américains qui sont
affilié à des tendances radicales de
droite et qui sont parmi les contenus
les plus partagés avec il y a un symbole
qui existe qui est celui de la déchéance
de la France et il est lié à à crépul et
enfin il y a un débat très clairement
sur le champ sémantique un lexite très
chargé parfois violent vous le savez les
racailles les barbares les sauvages
qu'on retrouve dans certaines enceintes
et qui est associé au fameux vivement le
9 juin qui est qui a été lancé par
Marine Le Pen donc il y a une vraie
activation d'une stratégie des réseaux
d'extrême droite avec aussi une
contestation du du Mont Rix alors qui ne
préjuge pas de
la de de l'importance du phénomène qui
reste qui est devenu un phénomène
politique mais aussi un un fait de
société c'est vrai mais l'activation de
l'extrême droite est très très forte et
elle est vue en tant que telle par
beaucoup d'internautes sur les réseaux
sociaux merci beaucoup if San 9 juin
évidemment les élections européennes
Mathieu souquier c'est c'est assez
passionnant ce que vient de nous dire if
Sani notamment sur le les les les les
comptes qui viennent de d'autres pays là
des États-Unis qui finalement Activ la
machine médiatique aussi autour d'un
fait d'hiver comme comme celui-là
comment vous l'analysez et est-ce qu'on
est peut-être un peu trop tôt pour le
dire là aussi mais dans une stratégie à
6 mois quoi ou à voilà si on se projette
dans le cadre des européenes il y a eu
aussi ce qui s'est passé à Dublin par
exemple voilà une attaque au couteau des
manifestations d'extrême droite dans les
très violentes dans les jours qui ont
qui ont suivi alors il y a il y a une
Internationale des nationalistes qui se
constitue effectivement et c'est la
magie des réseaux sociaux ça permet
précisément de faire ce
qu'historiquement les nationalistes
n'ont pas réussi à faire alors dans
l'histoire de l'extrême droite il y a
toujours eu une instrumentalisation
d'ffets divers ça ça a existé
précisément à toutes les époques en tout
cas depuis que l'extrême droite existe
et à l'époque de Jean-Marie Le Pen
c'était papivoise en pleine campagne
présidentielle il y a toujours eu ça
puisque derrière encore une fois la
stratégie du du rassemblement national
enfin de l'extrême droite dans son
ensemble c'est de c'est d'arriver à
consolider une vision de la société
uvagée une société violente de plus en
plus VI très violente de plus en plus
violente donc de se poser évidemment
comme rempart de cette violence et
deuxième dimension de d'accréditer
l'idée que cette violence ou cette
montée de la violence qui n'est pas
toujours documentée mais que cette
montée de la violence précisément serait
directement lié au fait migratoire et
puis du fait migratoire il y a il y a
les migrants il y a ceux qui arrivent
aujourd'hui puis il y a tous ceux qui
sont à arrivé dans le passé mais qu'on
finit par associer à ceux qui sont les
nouveaux arrivants donc voilà donc cette
stratégie en fait elle est très ancienne
elle est elle est en tout cas
aujourd'hui très efficace et ça reboucle
avec ce que vous disez tout à l'heure la
stratégie la plus efficace face à
l'extrême droite personne ne l'a trouvé
c'estàdire que le combat moral le combat
sur les valeurs ça fait effectivement 40
ou 50 ans qu'on le mène ça n'empêche pas
l'extrême droite de prospérer de ce
point de vue-là il y a pas seulement en
fait des des désaccords au sein du
gouvernement ou à la tête de l'État il y
a même une forme d'incohérence enfin je
veux dire on a du pont moréti qui dis ce
qu'il dit aujourd'hui mais il y a
quelques mois il y avait Gérald daranin
qui reprochait à Marine à Marine Le Pen
sa molae qui instruisait le procès en
Mola de Marine Le que là ça encore
changé parce qu'avec le déplacement
d'Olivier verrand à Crépol avec ce qu'il
a dit aussi il va plusutôt dans le sens
de l'opinion publique au ouais donc on
on on y comprend plus rien et deuxième
dimension le combat sur les valeurs
effectivement il est sans efficacité le
combat sur les résultats c'estàd l'idée
que il suffirait de faire reculer le
chômage pour faire reculer l'extrême
droite on sait que c'est pas le cas
depuis Lionel Jospin et on a
confirmation avec avec Emmanuel Macron
ça ne marche pas d'avantage allez une
autre leçon de notre baromètre odoxa
mascaré pour Public Sénat et les tites
de la PQR les difficultés d'éliisabeth
borne popularité qui est stable 30 %
d'opinion favorable on peut voir ce
premier ce premier élément 69 %
d'opinion
défavoraable et puis il y a une autre
question ellisabeth borne doit-elle
rester première ministre et là le nom
l'emporte à 61 % latia ça se double d'un
d'un retour des rumeurs sur le
remaniement c'est de nouveau auudessus
de la tête d'Élisabeth borne apparemment
oui Thomas seulement 4 mois après que
Emmanuel Macron l'ai maintenu c'était en
juillet hein dans son poste de première
ministre après la réforme mouvementée
des retraites elle aurait pu sauter à ce
moment-là Emmanuel Macron a décidé de la
garder et bien ça revient ces rumeurs et
toujours la même question borne
peut-elle tenir alors avant c'était
après la réforme de sur les retraites
maintenant ce sera après la loi
immigration qui est discutée en ce
moment au Parlement et aussi dans la
perspective des élections européenne
elle avait refusé elle voulait pas y
aller elle voulait pas être tête de
liste pourquoi parce qu'elle ne voulait
pas se retrouver sur un siège
éjectable en cas de grande victoire du
RN et là elle s'y retrouve quand même
Thomas pourquoi parce que dans tous les
sondages
apparemment les macronist c'est ce qui
se murmure auraiit quelques sueur froid
et et dirait que le RN pour l'instant
part grand gagnant et que si c'est le
cas en juin cela marquerait il y en a
qui vont fort carrément la fin du
dernier quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron et
ce serait la faute d'Élisabeth borne
est-ce que vous avez trouvé le même son
de cloche du côté de l'Élysée ce n'est
pas si évident du côté de l'Élysée pour
le moment le président serait ce qu'on
me dit en mode réflexion et il sondrait
à tout voir pour savoir s'il faut
remanier ou pas parce que figurez-vous
Thomas que il pourrait y avoir
uniquement un remanement ministériel
notamment après les procès du pont
Moretti et du sopt en fonction de
comment ça se passe en gardant Elisabeth
borne donc il y aurait ça c'est un mot
qu'Emmanuel Macron aime des ajustements
voilà la première ministre qui qui a
prévu forcément enfin on l'espère pour
elle une stratégie de défense oui elle
parle peu éisabeth borne elle a dit la
semaine dernière à la presse à propos de
ces rumeurs de remanimement ça fait 10
fois que j'entends ça c'est vrai mais ça
l'empêche pas d'agir elle agit elle agit
là dernièrement elle multiplie les
déplacements si vous êtes attentif vous
pouvez le remarquer et aussi des prises
de position fortes hier par exemple elle
a carrément rejeté le compromis sur la
l'assurance chômage à la barbe des
syndicats qui étaient furieux et et du
patronat aussi d'ailleurs et du patronat
oui
notamment euh bon elle demandait des
garanties sur les économies faites sur
lesocations des des senior enfin elle a
marqué en tout cas euh sa voilà elle a
posé sa marque et dans la majorité elle
prend les choses en main et ça commence
dès ce soir dès ce soir elle reçoit les
parlementaires ça va être cinq dîners
CIN réunions de travail on dit plutôt à
Matignon où elle reçoit les
parlementaires de la majorité pourquoi
pour lancer le premier ser semestre de
réforme dès janvier 2024 donc borne
c'est très simple le message qu'elle
envoie montre qu'elle est à sa tâche
allez une conclusion pourquoi elle est
de nouveau fragilisée écoutez on l'a vu
dans le sujet h et c'est vrai que quand
sa tangue c'est comme ça le Premier
ministre est inf fusible donc elle est
infusible en ce moment sa tangue depuis
la réforme sur les retraites et il y a
deux problèmes pour ellisabeth borne en
terme d'image déjà elle est masquée
presque même invisible à cause d'Édouard
Philippe et de cette popularité qui
reste très stable la pauvre ellisabeth
borne tant de subsister mais dans les
sondages on voit qu'elle est carrément
invisibilisée
et aussi autre problème d'image quand
même elle est la madame 493 multiplié
sur les textes budgétaires or quand on
sonde les Français vous êtes bien placés
pour le savoir le 493 cette mesure est
jugée par une grande partie de la
population comme un dénis de démocratie
donc c'est largement impopulaire et
cette impopularité lui colle à la peau
merci létia quelques mots rapides sur
Elisabeth band il il y a un côté
supplice chinois quand même Sophie
Coignard je sais bien que le le c'est le
lot de tous les premers ministres d'ê
sur un siège éjectable mais là c'est
j'ai l'impression ça ça revient ça
revient tous les deux TR mois quoi il un
raffinement particulier euh alors on
voit bien que ellisabeth borne elle est
à la
fois comment dirais-je c'est une dure à
cuire et en même temps elle elle en elle
en a assez enfin je veux dire aussi je
déclenche l'article 493 en fait c'est
une
phrasequelle on peut plus supporter
euh souvenons-nous quand même puisqu'on
parlait d'Édouard Philippe qu'eddouard
Philippe effectivement une des raisons
pour lesquelles on l'a remercié de
Matignon c'était qu'il était plus
populaire que le président alors si je
puis dire longéit Elizabeth B ne court
pas ce risque là donc essayons de voilà
essayons de positiver pour elle c'est
pour ça qu'emuel Macron va peut-être la
garder remagant et et d'une certaine
manière les les les enfin Emmanuel
Macron a a déjeuné récemment avec
Nicolas Sarkozi
euh Nicolas Sarkozi son son idée a
plutôt été d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a
fait d'user un premier ministre jusqu'à
la corde et et Elisabeth
borne peut encore servir il y a quand
même des gens dans la majorité qui qui
disent justement à cause de cette
échéance des européennes que ce serait
complexe de griller la cartouche du
changement de Premier ministre avant euh
les élections de juin parce que si
jamais c'est effectivement une
catastrophe pour la
majorité il faudra encore changer
peut-être de Premier ministre
effectivement qui serait le meilleur
pour remplacer on se projette hein la
plupart du temps d'ailleurs ça se passe
comme ça c'est lié aux élections quand
mêmeid évidem vous avez sondé aussi
l'opinion sur le le le le meilleur
remplaçant enfin le meilleur successeur
pour être précis qui serait le meilleur
premier ministre voilài je vais pas
faire un c'est pas un grand scoop c'est
la la comète du moment c'est Gabriel àal
qui est cité en premier voyez à 30 %
hmanto le 27% loin devant Gérald qui est
le le malaimé de l'opinion et devant
Julien de Normandie et Sébastien LEC nu
qui tous deux souffrent d'un d'un gros
déficit de notoriété en réalité avant de
de parler d'impopularité de de ces
deuxlà pour Gabriel Attal et Bruno
leemire ils sont un peu dans un mouchoir
de poche en réalité avec des soutiens
assez différents c'est-à-dire que par
exemple Gabriel hatal est quelqu'un qui
est très apprécié y compris à droite
compris par les sympathisants de LR sur
sa côte il est même au-dessus de Bruno
Le Maire mais vous voyez quand on pose
la question qui vous préférez comme
premier ministre là les sympathisants de
droit disent Bruno Le Maire de même que
d'ailleurs les sympathisants de
Renaissance comme s'il y avait une
espèce de quand même de gage à la
maturité la stature l'expérience
politique on dit non là quand même quand
même Bruno Le Maire mais on voit quand
même que Gabriel àal progresse de
manière spectaculaire sur notre
baromètre en en popularité
en terme dans l'opinion de manière
détaillée il est considéré comme un bon
ministre de l'Éducation toutes les les
pistes de réformes qu'il a proposé sont
vraiment acclamés par l'opinion et puis
en plus vous parlez de Gabriel on VO BR
le derrière vous c'est bien
gabav pastris le moi je vois devant moi
j'ai l'impression que je parle de lui et
voilà donc donc vraiment là en voilà en
tant que Premier ministre ça pourrait en
effet avoir du sens sans doute politique
a de pouvoir mettre quelqu'un qui soit
jeune et qui soit considéré comme
quelqu'un bah de courageux de compétent
et et de fidèle ce qui peut servir allez
il nous reste allez un peu plus de 5
minutes comme promis on va parler de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je propose à Quentin
calmer de de de nous rejoindre on va
voir s'afficher l'un des enseignements
de la l'étudeoxa bonsoir Quentin avec la
code de confiance de Jean-Luc mélanchot
compte de confiance qui est à seulement
% bon c'est une chute constante c'est ça
oui c'est même une nette baisse depuis
juin dernier Thomas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui est passé de la 6e place des
politiques dans leur code de confiance à
la 17e il devient même à l'inverse l'une
des personnalités les plus clivantes ce
qui qui provoque le plus de rejet à 60 %
des Français interrogés c'est juste
derrière éc Zemour qui est à 62 % pour
autant Jean-Luc Mélenchon reste la
personnalité la plus en vue à gauche
absolument mais attention là encore ça
baisse mais à 44 % d' il a perdu deux
points en un mois et c'est 12 points
depuis le mois de juin selon l'étude il
rejoint un groupe de personnalité au
tout de 40 % d'adhésion à gauche dont
Fabien Roussel Édouard Philippe et
François Ruffin l'étude note pourtant
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon devançait de 15
points toutes ces personnalités avant
l'été et donc si on rentre dans le
détail il est jugé trop radical voilà
pour expliquer les mauvais chiffres
depuis juin dernier effectivement le
point de départ c'est la stratégie
d'obstruction à l'Assemblée nationale
pendant la période de la réforme des
retraites mais les critiques sont de
plus en plus vives depuis les massacres
du Hamas du 7 octobre exemple avec ce
tweet du 22 octobre où le fondateur de
la France insoumise s'en prend à yelbrun
Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui campe à TelAviv la ligne
Mélenchon est contesté en interne et
c'est nouveau et ce de plus en plus
ouvertement le 12 novembre dernier on
voit ainsi plusieurs élus insoumis
manifester contre l'antisémitisme
n'hésitons pas à se démarquer de la
position de et bien des du parti on voit
ainsi François Ruffin Raquel garido
Alexis corber et Clémentine otin défilé
à Strasbourg et mi novembre c'est la
députée Raquel garido qui est
sanctionnée par le groupe LFI de
l'Assemblée nationale pour ses prises de
position qui nuisent je cite au bon
fonctionnement collectif du groupe en
clair la direction du groupe LFI lui
reproche d'avoir critiqué Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et même de l'avoir revendiqué
dans le journal lobs un conflit s'ouvre
entre la députée et la direction de LFI
écoutez Raquel garido c'était
mi-novembre sur not notre
antenne il y a un problème à la
Direction de la France insoumise il y a
besoin d'avoir à mon à mon sens un
sursaut là un sursaut
éthique j'ai l'impression que leur
boussole je sais pas c'est c'est c'est
déboussolé voilà elle elle ne marche
plus donc il y a besoin que les insoumis
voilà se se ressaisissent fassent du
commun dans l'unité des élum sont peu
nombreux à s'en prendre directement à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon voilà tout se fait à
fleur et moucheté effectivement même un
député comme François Ruffin qui joue
pourtant sa propre partition depuis
plusieurs semaines et bien il propose
une alternative à gauche mais sans
jamais se mettre vraiment à dos son
ancien chef de file écoutez c'était
dimanche dernier sur France 3 est-ce que
pour vous Jean-Luc Mélenchon reste une
référence comment ne serait pas une
référence l'homme qui a permis de sauver
la gauche dans le pays il faut bien voir
que si la gauche ça avait été François
Hollande et son fils adoptif Emmanuel
Macron la gauche elle serait morte et
enterrée aujourd'hui donc il a sa place
dans votre nouveau mouvement le
mouvement il est plus large que ça la
mouvement c'est la gauche en général il
que Jean-Luc Mélanchon a sa place dans
dans dans dans le pantéon de la gauche
pas tourne la gauche mais ça veut dire
un peu dans notre passé hein on est bien
compris dans la bouche de de François
rifin absolument mais donc on l'entend
pour l'heure il s'agit pour lui plutôt
de de poser d'autres cartes sur la table
à gauche sans jamais lancer de
confonflet ouvert on l'a compris avec
Jean-Luc mé merci beaucoup Quentin
Mathieu souer je me tourne vers vous
parce que faire émerger une alternative
à Jean-Luc Mélenchon à LFI est-ce
possible sans quitter LFI vous voyez ce
que je veux dire alors sans quitter
lesfi ça paraît compliqué et même je
dirais qu'en quittant LFI ça va ça va
l'être en réalité la question posée la
question sousjacente et celle
effectivement de la posture politique et
de la stratégie politique Jean-Luc
Mélenchon fait évidemment tout ce qu'il
fait de façon sont totalement
construites totalement pensées il fait
le Paris que cLIV aujourd'hui
politiquement et y compris aller dans
l'outrance dans l'excès et dans la
violence c'est pas seulement la
radicalité mais dans la violence ça a
vocation à payer à terme alors ce qui
est sûr c'est que à ce stade dans les
enquêtes d'opinion Marine Le Pen par une
posture radicalement opposée a plier le
match des opposants ça c'est
incontestable en terme de proximité de
danger de compéten de tout ça en fait
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est à ce stade à ce
stade en tout cas distancé alors il
avait connu une vraie chute après la
dernière présidentielle et puis il avait
l'avant- dernière présidentielle et puis
il avait réussi à remonter jusqu'à un
score tout à fait inédit en en 2022 et
donc on voit bien que il se dit que en
réalité il peut y avoir des creux de
vagues et que les creux de vagues ne
sont jamais
définitifs c'est c'est un Paris ce qui
est sûr c'est que aujourd'hui alors que
l'opinion de gauche était unitaire à 80
% il y a un an encore elle ne l'est plus
majoritairement aujourd'hui 80 % des
sympathisants de gauche disaient il y a
un an nous devons faire l'unité et il
n'y a pas de GA irréconciliable ce qui
nous rapproche dépasse ce qui nous
divise aujourd'hui en revanche à partir
de de précisément en fait de la posture
du du leader insoumis ce ne sont plus
que 46 % des sympathisants de gauche qui
se disent unitaires donc la nupes a pris
cher quand même merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat sur
public sén je vous dis à très bientôt